- Zachary! Where's the remote?
- [Announcer:] Oh, what a catch by Garrett Wilson!
- Ugh, just turn the TV on.
- [Brock:] Every off season,
after losing the NFC Championship game,
[Brock:] Coach likes to spend time at the beach
with his expensive offensive weapons.
- Woo! Who needs a QB when we're all loaded?!?
- Sorry, kid.
I'm not ready to commit
to the whole “franchise QB” thing.
- [Brock:] To them that was irrelevant.
[Brock:] But this summer, something changed.
Hey guys.
- Whoa.
- Brock got hot.
- Au chante.
- [Zach:] Okay, this looks really good.
- Oh, grow up, Zach.
It's a f--king fairy tale.
- Don't you see?
You're the guy, Brock.
I dumped Trey for you.
- But you gave up so much for him.
Like you did embarrassing things to pursue him, and-
- Shhhh...
- This is an expensive pop song.
- Ugh, change it!
- Aaron, I have a whole team I need to give attention to-
- SOMETHING. ELSE.
- Okay, so we pretend you're an elite
QB to make my ex jealous.
- [Rodgers:] I'm not jealous.
- Maybe you are an elite quarterback.
No, no. It’s too soon.
- [Rodgers:] Anything else!
- Doug Pederson was hoping to go all the way this year.
And he knew just the partner.
- Wow. Maybe there is hope
for these young kids after all.
- No, being young is bad.
It is scary and it is confusing.
Look!
- Glendale is under attack!
Pew, pew, pew! Shots, shots, explosions! Too much plot! I need help.
- Sorry, fam. That sounds like a Dobbs job.
- Oh hell yeah, this is so terrible I love it.
- Who am I?
I’m the guy who watched Goldmember a thousand times. Who are you?
- [VO:] Nathaniel Hackett IS...
The OC.